[Music]
former cowboys receiver dez bryant who
knows a thing or two about negotiating
against the joneses he chimed in
yesterday on the dak prescott contract
situation paydak is 40 million and don't
at me and that 40 million dollar number
wasn't something that dez bryant pulled
out of thin air chris sims there was a
report yesterday from nfl media the
operation partially owned by the dallas
cowboys that
dak prescott wants 40 million per year
on average in a new contract i was
quickly told all caps false dak prescott
is not looking for 40 million per year
and there were reports back in june he
was in the mid 30s 34 something like
that and look if you give them the jimmy
garoppolo contract right now the new
money average would be north of 30
million dollars because he's only due to
make two million this year it gets very
complicated very quickly and there are
different ways you can look at it but
there is no way to look at any of dak
prescott's demands and come to a
conclusion that he wants 40 million
dollars per year i'm told and others
like chris mortensen of espn have
reported the same thing so chris i look
at this and i say the cowboys are
exasperated with these contractual
stalemates they're in
and they're trying to paint that
prescott is greedy and we've seen this
before and if you can paint the player
as greedy what happens the fans start to
put pressure on him he starts to feel
the heat and he's more likely to take
the offer under the terms that the team
is willing to put on the table and it's
unfortunate if that's what deliberately
was done to try to squeeze him and i
think dak prescott smart enough to see
through it and probably not happy about
it yeah i i would think so i mean this
certainly these type of rumors you
always expect come from the organization
somehow some way just to yes bad
propaganda uh one i would be shocked if
dak prescott asked for 40 million
dollars a year he just doesn't come off
as that type of human being he's shown
nothing of that selfishness or me me me
type attitude and not to say hey
everybody wants to get paid and i
understand that but i do think this is a
guy that's conscious of being a leader
he's conscious of the rest of the
football team around him and all that
the cowboys have made comments saying
they feel good they made an offer that
would make him top five in in football
as far as money right um
i would love to know what that number is
is it aaron rodgers is it carson wentz
you know either way i know he doesn't
deserve 40 million a year i mean this is
one thing i'm all for the players
getting paid but i don't like that every
new guy at the contract gets to one-up
the last guy that signed it and he
becomes the highest paid player in the
nfl to me that's something the owner's
got to stop you know you know hey at the
end of the day yeah i don't think dak
prescott deserves to be paid like
russell wilson ben roethlisberger aaron
rodgers i respect his game and i know
everything's awesome but i'm kind of
just sick of that trend in general and i
think it's stealing money off of you
know joe average player or joey i'm on
the bottom of the roster's uh money to
where yeah they don't spread the wealth
because the new guy at the big positions
the star always gets extra money because
he has to become the highest paid at his
position in the history of the nfl and i
think that's kind of wrong i don't get
that
well first of all nobody's forcing the
teams to pay these guys and second of
all until every team is spending 100 of
the allotted cash available under the
salary cap the idea that they're robbing
peter to pay paul is just flat out false
now in dallas where they seem to be more
inclined to spend to the cap that
becomes a realistic issue and they've
made that point not that long ago
stephen jones said we're not doing this
to cram money into our pockets every
dollar we give to one guy is one last
dollar we have for the other guy but but
still
dak prescott's not trying to one-up
russell wilson to become the
highest-paid quarterback in nfl history
there was a period of time there where
the quarterback market wasn't growing at
the rate that it should have been
growing and we went through the andrew
luck to derek carr right to matthew
stafford jimmy garoppolo kirk cousins
matt ryan each guy got more than the one
before him prescott's trying to fall in
there somewhere between russell wilson
and matt ryan in that range of 30 to 35
million and chris i just did the math
and this is the example i don't want to
put anybody to sleep or give anyone a
migraine this early including myself
if you give dak prescott the jimmy
garoppolo contract right now if you tear
up the deal that he has left one season
at 2 million and you say dak you've done
enough you've done far more to deserve
five years 27.5 million the jimmy
garoppolo ever did and you know what
that statement is true yeah if you give
that to dak prescott right now okay it's
a five-year 27.5 million dollar contract
if you do the new money analysis because
you what he's all ready to do to make
this year it's 33.8
million per year in new money that's how
these numbers get out of whack the
bottom line is right and do you agree
with me right now the cowboys should
give him the jimmy garoppolo contract
and that would be regarded as a good
deal for the cowboys if they would do
that yes i do i agree with you right now
take it sign it i mean the cowboys
should do it you know even dak prescott
i'm sure they're going to argue for more
money but i would be very comfortable i
know if i was in his situation and
that's easy for me to say sitting here
in a studio at nbc sports but still you
know i i look at that and go okay you
know 33.8 million okay i'm the third
highest paid quarterback at all of
football the third highest paid player
in all of football and things are going
in the right direction but yeah i mean
to your point you're spot on he has
every every
bit of leverage to argue for more money
than garoppolo derek carr
um and who else am i missing on that
list because her cousins and carson
wentz he could argue all of them that he
should one-up every single one of those
guys on the list
well now now you now we're in definitely
into the low 30s and new money with
carson wentz right
so and look
he's right in the spot where i think you
can get behind it he doesn't want more
than russell wilson he doesn't want to
set the bar higher than it's ever been
set i mean if if this leak from the
cowboys is to be believed and it
shouldn't be he's trying to take 35 and
increase it by 5 million a year are you
kidding me i can't believe anybody would
even fall for that yeah and so that that
to me chris
that is the most troubling indication
yet as it cut as it relates to the
cowboys i think that they're getting
exasperated with this i think that they
they don't know how to deal with these
guys the old ways of negotiating aren't
working otherwise they would have a
contract with one of their three key
players that they're trying to get deals
done with and i think we're starting to
see that this this leak i think they're
getting a little wobbly here they don't
know what to do with zeke they don't
want to do a dak they don't know what to
do with amari cooper and i think that
they're starting to feel the walls close
in on them a little bit yeah well they
should i mean they're in the super bowl
window and they're gonna they're gonna
you know for lack of a better phrase
piss off their three best players on the
offensive side of the ball so they
should feel a little pressure you know
what what would the it may be i mean
this is the other thing i'm just
throwing this out there if he's asking
for 40 million dollars a year but not
tearing up the two-point point whatever
million he's supposed to get this year
what does that average come out to be
maybe he's but he's not yeah it's
probably low 30s right but but still
he's not asking for 40 million a year
under any analysis
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports